hey Mary
Reggie taught me a new Tagalog phrase he
said it's really romantic
Molly done T Tico Reggie magodonga be
sign young lahat nakita naminé on video
call nan de luang lingo known Taplin
ling gonna a whole nother man tagalog at
Atilla mass murder noona ho mad tagalog
night nian kaiser
noon pedal made up pauline and tagalog
palace are in Niagra gusto kong makka
pakka's ups a sub alone at lingo
Valentine's Day Nong Saba home at dito
Sahab on Bennigan's and manga baba a non
chocolate chocolate a and Maga lalaki
kiya Akuma Honan madam in chocolate a at
mass mat Abajo nay on kiya
de pata Hong Maha her CCO Lalo at Moroni
Hong
magandang bolita familia Honan camera
nah GoPro kiya Gaga meeting cojito con
pop-unders appeal apenas sally sang
lingo naka pal de tank an on camera
pero maganda on video neato kiya messiah
ho at Nabila ho sunbae tkachenko OC gay
bi alright that's just another little
sample of my progress and tagalog how
it's going obviously I'm not fluent I
can express myself about simple things I
can make simple sentences I can
communicate about basic things with
basic vocab but for three weeks in I'm
pretty happy with how things are going
I'm looking forward to my trip to
Philippines next week and I'll try out
my Tagalog there more and practice more
and I'm going to study while I'm there
hopefully that will expand my ability
even more Tagalog is an interesting
experience the only other thing I can
compare it to is when I started studying
Japanese way back like in the beginning
years and years ago because before that
I had only studied languages that were
much more similar to English like I had
studied French in school I had studied
Hebrew and modern Hebrew kind of has
syntax that's similar to English like
the word order is different from
Biblical Hebrew it's more like English
so when I started learning Japanese the
word order and the grammar sentence
structure was something completely
different
it kind of was difficult at first and
freak me out a bit like because I had to
think in a whole new way and piece
together the ideas to make sentences in
a completely new way couldn't just
change out the words like you can in
some other languages and now Tagalog is
kind of similar to that similar to the
old days when I started Japanese and I
was freaking out about this completely
new way of expressing myself and
take-out looks kind of like that that
you can't just change the words out into
tagalog words you can't just take an
English sentence and change the words
into Tagalog it won't happen here won't
you won't be able to express yourself
like that adults no one would understand
it's a totally different experience so
that's quite fun quite interesting to do
that's quite mind-bending and it makes
me think in new ways and I always enjoy
that so yep that's another look at how
it's going I hope you are busy studying
too and improving at whatever language
you're focused on good night